okay random challenge oh I'm missing
both rooks double rakaats double records
and I'm black okay it's five plus two so
slightly quicker time control let's take
this seriously I'm gonna try and and not
open any files if all the files stay
closed and the routes will have a hard
time entering the game so it's hippo
time don't mess with the hippo
my viewers are tough on me Oh in terms
of what positions yeah but that's how
you become tough yourself to endure some
tough tough viewers and tough positions
yeah so files are closed as long as all
the files are closed and rooks are are
irrelevant have you taken the hippo cry
echoes ah ha ha I never really aspired
to me a doctor at least a medical doctor
I've seen a hippo guys want to see a
hippo its secretive searching my google
photos I saw a hippo in Thailand hungry
hippo there's a photo I took in Chiang
Mai or you you just you feed the hippos
but ok this is the seppo is slightly
different my phone's not feeding me you
see yet
hmmm a problem I want to develop the
knight and the pawns lost well thanks
for subbing more people
the Queen ate a Queenie sudden just be
solid waiting for some opportunity
thanks everyone for subbing kumamoto 9
something with twitch crime and yes um
it's Oh Jace myth Vestal also something
with which crime thanks so much and say
kiss kiss
something something at tier 1 for 8
months yeah ok this is what I like to
see
well it's admiral gifting more subs and
Rui something with twitch fine ooh my
opponents my phone's feeding me I like
to be fed oh and I get to play f6 double
win
thanks Admiral gifting a sub in so many
subs to Beau Jan something something
3000 worlds a piece of pecan pie master
Kings 101 this is going to be sad Bishop
ooh and I'm even more sad night I kind
of blundered and chess is cheese ok
eponymous h7 would have trapped the
Knights the problem is the files are
opening so rooks are becoming more
relevance but that's ok try and fight a
little bit of time pretty much done with
my tea I love more files opening ones
playing like a fine strategy play this
move
activated lights Oh t-con prepared the
most scrambled board ever mean these
position like the front position looking
forward to that oh no security breach
those files were classified and
shouldn't have been opened wait oh oh oh
Admiral with more puns I get it
try to understand that for a moment all
men but what to do I want to take but it
opens a file
maybe other night wants to develop to
whether it has a hard time takes I'm
just gonna have to wait and chill and
wait for my opportunity Benjy Bob thanks
for subbing for ten months
thanks again Admiral awful 1000 bits the
file ton really haven't heard file B
uses upon before
so okay yeah this is this is a very
troublesome file this is a corrupt file
what you do you so Queen I'm just gonna
chill for a bit longer
Eric you're so funny
oh thank you I mean but the Admiral is
paneer right I think also did I show
this picture I don't know if I show this
picture there's another hippo picture
this is a hippo at the st. Louis Zoo and
it was wanted to eat me this one this
Bishop is actually performing a very
useful job preventing whites from making
a queen
and this mission needs to find a better
job those file pans are so Mesopotamia
is Mesopotamia is that just a word that
you can use in place of any other word
still trying to understand it these
files are staying close its maneuver and
the try and attack with everything I
have on the queenside
I guess most people still don't
understand with what Mesopotamia means
the queen is not the happiest [ __ ] hater
positions like this you always have to
look on the bright side like my king say
I have the bishop hair to pawn James I
have the knight pair to
I'm not sure what my plan is just to
keep things as complicated keep things
wok hated
Oh SWA's meet odds with a fun fact if
anyone wants a fun fact about hippo look
at what Suarez Matar Sen also sua's
mattias after focus perhaps people don't
know Mesopotamia means but perhaps they
know what it modes or medians okay what
omo modes and meet those are statistical
terms but is it related wait Rhino wants
to promote I understand now let's trap a
bishop bishop is trapped let's go I feel
like in a few moves like I'm gonna be
down two or three queens but at least
I'm trapping a bishop I recently had to
explain to a mortgage advisor that your
monthly outgoing tongue out I don't know
how I understand any of this okay
White's making a new queen
let's keep attacking a bad feeling about
this
I've a really bad feeling about this
when in doubt attack like my kings still
safe I have a plan storm also have a
slight time of damage why not take the
bishop because a bishop and the knight
are now attacked I'm just trying to
confuse my opponents this plot this
plans gonna Queen very soon Oh stick
with me
here and then here and there and
something wait you just after Queen I
just sacked a clean white defended I was
hoping I wouldn't see my threats poet
saw it to the smooth so I'm only down
faster this I mean down a queen and two
rooks and a pawn
okay this is actually kind of an
exciting finale Oh White's Acton's
White's Act two queens White's playing
the double vote as Gambon's my king is
still remarkably safe it's gonna try and
meet me but not if I'm eight white first
Waunakee Wow the little boat s cam it
this is a whole plan to check meet ya
might be YouTube worthy people on
YouTube I don't know if you made it to
this point and to survive all those pun
and Mesopotamia bits got the wind it's
thanks so much Admiral on the key thanks
for the game I need a double of records